what exactly is in that criminal code
people think abortion is 1 legal right
but unlike that it is 1 crime
and it is in Article 296
and that is actually determined
in short,
that anyone who performs 1 abortion
is punishable so the doctor is punishable unless
all kinds of requirement are met
for example from the Termination of Pregnancy Act
even unless it is done in 1 special clinic
to special abortion doctors
and in the termination of pregnancy law
are actually even more requirements
and adjust when 1 everything is met
then it is no longer punishable
and what about the women
women living with themselves
do something yourself to do 1 abortion
that is not punishable
for example after week 24
is only everyone
who performs 1 abortion,
for example 1 abortion doctor
that is punishable
yes it is so potential
criminal
unless all kinds of requirements are met